let's go next to our caller from the
seven eight one area code who is calling
today from seven eight one hi David this
is Steven Elias can hear me yes we're
not on any kind of weird device
speakerphone or Bluetooth right no not
right now sorry about that okay no
problem go ahead so with Thanksgiving
coming up I know a lot of us are gonna
be sitting down at the table with people
that we deeply love but who may hold
beliefs that are kind of dangerous and
it's not just talking about you know I'm
on the left I'm not just talking about
people who are on the right I'm talking
about people who are aunt Eve acts who
staunchly don't believe in climate
change in any capacity
they don't just sort of have some nuance
to be you on the scale or something how
do you think we should approach those
people if you know you do need to try
and start making ground on talking to
some of them about this stuff and
informing them yep but if you make them
feel cornered and insulted it's gonna do
a disservice to the things you believe
in because your beliefs will seem
farther out to them than they ever have
yep so here's my idea no so here's the
trick as I'm understanding it from you
on the one hand these are people you
don't want to ruin a relationship with
you don't want to ruin Thanksgiving you
don't want to be the Grinch that stole
Thanksgiving so to speak but at the same
time you don't really feel good about
just avoiding the dangerous beliefs that
some of these people have whether they
are anti-vaxxer or whatever else so I
think here's the happy medium and what I
recommend apply or employ maybe better
said a respectful sort of Socratic
method of questioning not about the
facts per se but about how the people
came to believe what they believe check
out Anthony Magna Bosco's a YouTube
channel where he does Street
epistemology for some of the the
technique and maybe apply a little more
soften it a little more because it might
be family or friends or whatever the
case may be
and simply all you're trying to do is
step one at Thanksgiving right you don't
you're not trying to argue all the facts
but you want to get people to at least
question how they're coming to their
conclusions and
start to respectfully inquire about
that's interesting how long have you had
that position how did you learn about it
where did you learn about it is that a
source that you've determined is
trustworthy how do you determine that a
source is trust trustworthy
most people will very quickly realize
that the foundation upon which their
beliefs are built is not nearly as
strong as they believe and it's just
step one you know and then maybe at
Hanukkah or Christmas then you go to
step two or whatever the case may be
yeah all right very good
okay great to hear from you short and
sweet I like it